bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission les
petits bricoleurs je vous propose
aujourd'hui de réaliser un bijou de sac
pour la fête des mares
pour cela nous avons besoin d'un
mousqueton ou d'un anneau
quelques rubans
un bouton
du fil et une aiguille
les quelques décorations comme des
perles
des pierres
des petites fleurs
et des petits coeurs
d'abord nous allons faire le montage
donc on va prendre toutes les rubans de
différentes grandeurs différentes
donc on va les mettre ensemble
on prend son mousqueton donc on fait
passer tous les rubans
à l'intérieur
mais si c'est trop grand port a coupé
les rues d'auch
maintenant va coudre le bouton là mais
si vous n'avez pas de boutons par
exemple vous pouvez faire aussi au mieux
ça j'aime pas vous pouvez faire aussi un
mieux donc là on va mettre le bouton
alors je prends mon aiguille
que j'ai déjà auparavant
et encore sans boutons
on passe une troisième fois
et on fait un petit velours
voilà donc ça va vous donner ça
et ensuite il suffit de rajouter les
petites décorations
votre vie mais pour la petite perle
tombe
beaucoup c'est rajouter de perles
là ce que ça donne en enfilant la terre
il faut la laisser là comme ça
on fait toujours un noeud
ça va fermer pour ne pas
on va coller quelques pierres
et on va coller sur le
voilà on a eu quelques pierres aux
petits coeurs
veut même rajouté une petite fleur et
que vous pouvez écrire aussi bonne fête
maman maman je t'aime
le prénom de la maman comme vous voulez
moi
cela
reste que ça donne
je la considère un petit peu là
un concert aux gens qu'on peut oublier
pour presser pour ajouter d'autres
décorations pouvez rajouter au sinon on
veut laisser comme ça
le bijou de sac étant terminée j'espère
que ça vous a plu me reste qu'à
souhaiter à toutes les mamans une bonne
fête et à la prochaine émission enfin